[Music]
I'm Emily Cummins I'm the assistant
objects conservator at the Toledo Museum
of Art in Toledo Ohio
I'll be walking you through how we use a
gel poultice to deep clean the columns
capitals and archways in our medieval
Cloister Gallery which dates range from
the 12th century to the 15th century
so this is the first time that these
arcades have been deep cleaned since
their accession at the Toledo Museum of
Art almost a hundred years worth of dirt
and grime is accumulated on the surface
The Cloister Gallery at the TMA is
composed of multiple pieces of various
Cloisters they're all from Southern
France although the elements of The
Cloister have been dry cleaned over time
they really hold on to the dirt and oily
Grime in the surface in those network of
pores in the upper layers
so we decided to start on the columns
because they are generally smoother than
the capitals for instance which have
carvings that are more three-dimensional
that stick out more into space and are
therefore a little bit more difficult to
apply an even layer of gel to
First the gelling agent is mixed with
water without any other cleaning
ingredients added this is done so that
the gelling agent can really hydrate as
much as it needs to so we don't have
clumps in the final gel now once the
water and the gelling agents sit
together for 10 to 12 hours then we'll
add the rest of our cleaning ingredients
now in the gel we have two cleaning
ingredients one surfactant and one soap
the surfactant helps break the
interfacial tension between the grime
and the stone and the soap helps
dissolve all of the oils that are in the
grime
we also use a plasticizer which allows
the dried film to be a little bit more
flexible and easier to peel off and then
finally we have a small amount of a
drying agent which helps set the film on
the surface of the stone to minimize the
amount of Dripping that we have because
we are fighting against gravity
Stone I think generally appears to be a
really robust material but it's actually
really poor it's Marble and limestone in
particular
the gel when it's applied to the surface
sort of uses capillary action the water
in the gel impregnated with those
cleaning ingredients is forced into the
pores of the stone and helps break the
bond between the grime and the stone and
it's sort of a cyclical process so as
more water gets pushed into the stone
that grimy water gets pushed out and all
of the dirt and grime gets trapped in
that gel film
so we apply the gel with a brush to the
stone in a relatively thick layer as the
water evaporates from the gel the layer
shrinks so the gel is over 90 percent
water and so we are getting some
dimensional shrinkage and so the wet
application needs to be a little less
than a quarter of an inch thick which is
rather thick but a thicker wet
application will lead to an easier dry
removal
so the jealous checked periodically as
it dries to make sure that it's drying
evenly if we need to move the fans we go
ahead and do that to make sure that the
gel is sufficiently dry for us to peel
we really just check it with our hands
sort of testing the temperature and
seeing if it's a dry hard film or wet
jelly film
so once the gel film is fully dry we can
start the mechanical removal process to
take away all of that dirt and grime
that's collected in the gel
but generally speaking we'll use bamboo
skewers to actually sort of poke a
little hole into the gel underneath it
so that we and our participants can
really start the peeling process and
it's really important that when we peel
the gel we use what's called a sheer
pool so taking a loose flap of gel and
folding it back 90 degrees and peeling
it off that way so that it's less
abrasive to the stone
once the gel is dry what we're seeing is
all of that dirt and grime which has
accumulated in the stone over time
trapped onto the surface and really
trapped within that gel so when we
remove the gel we are removing almost
100 Years of dirt and grime with it
so after the broad sections of the dried
gel film are removed we check all of the
surfaces with ultraviolet light we use
handheld UV flashlights to check the
surfaces to see if there's any residual
gel film the gel fluoresces under UV
light so that we can really easily spot
any leftover residue and really go in
strategically and remove those sections
so once all of the surfaces are checked
with ultraviolet light and all of that
gel film is removed the final step to
really make sure that the surfaces are
cleared from all of that cleaning
solution is to use wet cloths to
actually wipe down all surfaces this
will also rehydrate any remaining gel on
the surface so that it becomes really
noticeable to the naked eye so that
anything that we missed with the UV
lights can then be removed
it's been very rewarding to see that
volunteers come together to have a sense
of community and ownership over this
really beloved space at the Toledo
Museum of Art
[Music]